so I want to talk about the the desktop
web and this is a term I believe I've
made up but that's that's okay too
and so when I talk about the desktop web
there's a few different flavors that I
consider there are basically web
applications that are it's a desktop
application that is just a wrapper
around a web application so if you look
at SLAC all it really does is some basic
notification things like that some light
desktop integration but overall it's
just it's loading the web page inside of
a frame but you want the desktop
integration right you want to like have
the presence have the notifications have
the video you know record things like
that that you have to have from the
desktop so so that's a pretty common
approach but recently we've come across
a lot of AI bees and they're also
completely built in these web languages
so Visual Studio code atom editor things
like that so we have frameworks like
electron and that's what Visual Studio
codes built on that's it's released by
its I think it's a github project and so
their atom editors also built on top of
that and there's other ones like in wjs
I think it became before electron and
then there are frameworks like Mac gap
which and just similar type of web
bridge framework and then there's native
web or mobile applications and they
they're come in a couple of different
varieties as well you have either and
you know another embedded WebKit window
or you have these like react native
where you write web technologies but it
makes native components and there's some
bridge there and then there are other
apps like another classification of apps
to me and those are like let's say
eclipse for example it has different
things that render in HTML and so they
embed WebKit but it's not their primary
window that's not their primary view and
so this talk is going to cover hopefully
a range of those it's easy to pick on
electron and it's security but you know
there's there are different problems
that you can have with different types
of embedded browser and in different
types of you know desktop web
applications
so exploiting the desktop we'll have I
personally you know don't know assembly
very well and and not that great at
reverse engineering so you know I'm an
app tech guy I've been doing app sack
for a really long time and this is
really interesting to me because you are
using just the basic web technologies
web you know hacking methodology is to
attack a desktop web application so and
there's a bunch of interesting questions
like what is same origin policy of a
desktop app you know you're not visiting
a URL what do you know what policy
should it have and then there are really
really interesting consequences like if
I can execute JavaScript sometimes that
can turn into remote code execution in a
lot of cases that can turn into remote
code execution so this slide is
hopefully unnecessary but just a quick
so what is what is markdown and why I'm
using it you know mark Doom is the title
so if basically we're exploiting
markdown to get this JavaScript
injection so if you preview a markdown
page and it can execute code can we can
we you know execute remote code can we
take over your desktop because you
previewed a you know text file and so
markdown is a format like Santa like
syntax language that it just does basic
formatting so a bold underline things
like that I'm sure you're all familiar
with it it's common on github and
bitbucket
and you know documentation like most
projects have documentation and markdown
so and there's also blog platforms which
I am a fan of you write your blog and
really basic formatting and get this
rendered HTML pipe so that's kind of the
thing all markdown parsers take in this
basic format like the first example here
and convert it to HTML tags so it makes
sense for a lot of these renderers
whether they're native applications are
not to embed WebKit or to embed some
browser renderer in order to show the
output because you know most of the
markdown parsers end up rendering HTML
so why is it so hackable there's not a
lot of official spec for markdown
but any of the specs that you read or
any of the markdown parses that you
handle there's one last thing that says
if you can't format it with markdown
just drop into HTML and write HTML and
so I think that's why all the parsers
like fall back to HTML because there's
kind of this exception that like you
know whatever's whatever's left whatever
you can't do we don't want to provide
ongoing spec so you know use HTML and I
think that that's really interesting and
becomes the problem like you know
normally you would expect markdown files
just to be basic basic haunted and
highlight and headings and stuff like
that but what happens when I put an
iframe into a markdown file in preview
it and in a lot of cases then you have
an embedded iframe and so you know I
think there is kind of a question is
like if I preview an HTML file on my
desktop it shouldn't all it also
shouldn't execute code right so even if
you're saying like maybe you shouldn't
be previewing a markdown file that you
don't trust at the end of the day it's
still supposed to be just a viewable
file right like Word documents aren't
supposed to execute code and when they
do this is like a dangerous pattern that
we should avoid a lot of these
techniques though so I'm talking about
markdown and markdown editors and all of
the IDs
but there are many applications that
have embedded browsers for different
reasons like slack or like we thought I
patients and all of these things apply
and so you know picking a markdown or
picking on IDs you really just want to
think about is there an embedded browser
and if I can I control code that gets
there and if so can we exploit that to
code execution so in this context and
we're talking about IDs you know who did
it wrong what was successful so there
was a problem with visual studio code it
hubs atom editor Dobby brackets Eclipse
had some interesting issues from wrote
code execution in text me which is
interesting because it's a native app
and really lightweight
jetbrains sweet and if you don't know
the JetBrains sweet it's it's pretty
robust there's a lot of those and then
there was a section of just markdown
editors that are that are just designed
as markdown preview and editors and
those are you know maybe a less common
but I believe Mac down is really common
if an editor doesn't have a preview mode
it's they're usually designed to spawn
that application to do with rendering so
like I said before electron is a
framework that allows you to write web
and HTML and their slogan is if you can
build a website you can build an
application may be so strong but if you
can hack a website you can definitely
hack it at occasion this is going to go
a little bit off-topic but I'm gonna
talk about a CVE that's directly an
electron and it really has nothing to do
with the IDE this came out like two days
ago so I wanted to cover it really quick
and this is a universal any application
that uses electron there's a couple of
caveats like it has to like use a custom
protocol handler so if you think about
Skype or discord or any of those
applications they're all built on
electron and there's even like a Bitcoin
wallet which is kind of terrifying but
they register a protocol handler so that
web pages can invoke and open them and
if you there's a flaw in all electron
amps where if you registered this
protocol handler the way it was
registered in Windows led to remote
execution and so if by chance you trust
slack and say our or Skype and say
always always open because I know this
application then a website could inject
some JavaScript into the page that would
you know make this XQ they didn't give
many details in in the CVE so I decided
to look through the code change and
there were a lot of changes in this
thing but at the bottom of it I found a
test case which is super handy if you're
trying to look for vulnerabilities just
see what they're testing tonight you
and so it really ended up as simple as
put you know a JavaScript tag with this
on it and the exodus is the Bitcoin
wallet and that'll open the calculator
on the local gear and it comes down to
you like the the way electron handles
you're the parameters that are passed
into the URL and then it responds
electron until all of your parameters
are together and electron is actually
you know an embedded Chrome and so all
of the chrome arguments are also
available to be passed in and so there
was some confusion there and now they
explicitly exclude a bunch of the chrome
arguments that are unsafe and I believe
they also use - - to pass along and yeah
they recommend if you can't update your
own electronic applications right away
to add this switch
if you can't bump electron to the newest
version as an end user though it means
that you should update every application
that is built on electron because it's
not like updating Java or updating flash
everyone has its own copy of so just
discord and slack they might they both
have the issue and updating one doesn't
magically fix the framework for you so
to get back on track a little bit
abusing electron so electron is a chrome
renderer and it has node behind it and
so there's you can write code in note
then you can embed a window a frame that
loads all of your viewpoints and
everything and then
there's actually a a light note
integrations so all of the node Global's
are passed into the web window which is
super dangerous if you think about it
because node itself can you know
anything node can do this web window can
do and there's a flag you can send to
your embedded web window to say it can't
access node but I mean that's kind of
the point these sites want to you know
embed it use node to do a desktop
notification so they enable it and it
assume that you'll never have remote
user code on this page so you know
Visual Studio code github brackets they
all use electron and so really when I
started playing with this I didn't
expect it to be this simple and so I
open up visual studio code I add a
script tag and then I know a little bit
of node J yes I know that child process
can be used to open another application
I desktop and sure enough it popped up
in a calculator I it was actually quite
shocking so I reached out to them and
talked to them and they added a couple
of fixes they ended up embedding content
security policy into the site which is
great and interesting they also had an
exception I guess they assumed that you
know executing JavaScript in an unsafe
way based on their prescribed stuff here
was not always what the user wanted so
they pop open a dialog when there's the
CSP violation and the user can opt out
of that which also kind of has its own
inherent problems because it ended up
being in the Dom that you also control
still so didn't help much so how can we
get around this
so CSP at the time I'm not sure when
this is resolved or not but I'm the
security policy is designed to prevent
you from you know from ulta from having
things injected in your site or
executing script in contexts or whatever
but it doesn't really care if you go to
a different page
that's kind of a problem for us because
the content security policy was injected
into the top of the page above our code
as this metadata so we're talking to its
a locally rendered website there's no
URL that it's hitting or socket that
it's hitting or anything else so that's
kind of a big problem there's that
everything all the content scared of
policy has to come from the document
that the user is controlling or that the
attacker is controlling so meta
redirects aren't controlled by that so
even though we don't have JavaScript
execution yet we can meta redirect to
another site in this Prowse or preview
window and now because they don't
control the top of our document anymore
because we shift it away to a domain we
control we control you know we won't set
our own CSP and then we can get this
remote code execution again and so yeah
there's there's a couple different
variants of it and then in the end it
ends up being the same thing on our new
site our remote code execution HTML on
the remote site that that's how we undo
that so how do they fix this problem
there's a couple of things you can do in
electron to explicitly say I don't want
you to navigate to a new page so I don't
want meta redirects I don't want you to
click on a form or a link or anything
else anytime you're going to navigate to
a new window don't allow that they also
finally disabled known integrations on
the window which is awesome if you need
to interact with node you can use post
message and some other internal services
and you can like there are better ways
to do it you shouldn't just allow the
browser to have everything node can do
so so really similar with github atom
editor so it really similar we can it
had some some basic things around like
what you can and can't do but we could
embed an iframe in that iframe you know
messing around this I made an HTML page
and in that page I had the same
JavaScript and it executes and that's
all well and good but there was a
problem where I couldn't give
a remote path so that path to RCE like
I'm not on your computer or I don't
control any other files theoretically on
a computer so how can we execute this
and it turns out that if you create an
unauthenticated or an anonymous NFS or
SMB share and typically those live on an
network but those can be remote and you
can just expose them to the world which
I wouldn't recommend doing unless you're
trying to be various but it actually
Auto mounts so when I embed this iframe
to this file location and now we're
talking about like the same origin
policy because you know the renderer for
the markdown preview is on file colon
slash slash and r1 if if I go to this
remote IP address it auto mounts to this
net directory on Mac and then it's a
similar path on Windows and so my remote
server is now in a folder location on
your computer that I know of so now I
control an HTML file that technically
lives know locally on disk and so that
worked well and then my remote slash
local script is doing the same thing we
had before they've actually had another
problem since then I don't remember what
exactly fixes they had to place for mine
they had another remote code execution
fairly recently someone else did and
since then looking at the mitigations
that they do they've enabled CSP they
disabled notes integrations which was
key and they also used Dom purify which
is a library that allows you to strip
out HTML and whatever kind of which
which is much better it seems like it
would be great
there's adobe brackets it's really
similar except that it actually
technically doesn't use electron and so
you same approach over all the same file
colon approach it just has this custom
integration you had to get it had an
embedded brackets thing and you had to
connect to a module to get access to
node it's a little more complex but
overall the same the same once you get
your node object by creating a fake
plugin object
you can execute code so the next part is
maybe a bit more interesting because
this affects things that aren't
necessarily electron applications right
so if you have an embedded if you just
have an embedded web browser and there's
no node integrations if I have
JavaScript access what does what does
that mean you know it's an embedded
browser on a page but like it doesn't
automatically guarantee remote code
execution what the question is so if I
have something like slack or gammer or
something like that and I send you a URL
if you click on it you don't want it to
render in the little chat preview window
like that doesn't make a lot of sense
you want it to open in the user's
default browser but how do you know what
the users default browser is it's a
little bit interesting because there's
there's not great reliable ways to
necessary I mean that you have to build
it for every OS you support and you have
to keep that up and and figuring out the
remote browser it's not always the
easiest thing to do so no one does it at
all instead you just ask the operating
system and say hey how would you open
example.com and normally it says like
Firefox or Chrome or whatever else and
if you said how do you open example com
whatever gif it would still use you know
your browser cuz you gave it an HTTP URL
what's interesting is if you send you
know hey operating system how would you
open this file colon slash slash URL and
give it a full path to something and we
you know like full path to calculator
app it doesn't open it in your default
renderer it actually opens it in your it
just opens it it just executes it if you
send it a file path to a word document
it would just open that word document it
would open it in Word or whatever
whatever you had installed as the
default editor so by design it's using
like a built-in on OSX it's using like
system open or accusing command exe
slash C or whatever it is but overall
it's just sending it to an open command
which isn't great but again so we
the same problem we have a like before
where you know we can't open local files
but we learned a trick for that and the
other problem is the file must be
executable but if it's a local file even
it when it comes to remote it's not
always executable I can't do plus X and
have it live locally for you so we end
up running into another sort of problem
it's an unsigned binary you know or it's
not executable if it comes from certain
you know origins so how do we work
around that and so sure we can locally
can open up the local calculator which
is great for demos by the way but it's
not great for I mean that's not that's
not the attackers objective right so it
turns out that you can take a you can
actually create an app file a dot app
file which is a standard Mac OS
application file by writing Apple script
and when you compile that you know in
the Apple script editor you can do
anything in there it's just a basic
scripting language and you can do
anything in there and when you push the
button to compile that you can export it
as an app well the thing is it's not
actually creating a binary it's creating
an app it's just this package and it's
just executing your Apple script but so
it opens automatically but there's no
signed binary there's no like permission
issues or anything else because it's not
actually a an executable right it's not
a binary it just happens to open
automatically and an executor script I
found that out a little bit later and
one of the tricks I was using before
that was OSX terminal has a dot terminal
file so the other thing you can do is
just say are there any applications on
the computer that went you know the
default behavior for this file type is
to run the file without it having plus
execute so come to find out this at the
sixth is a file called like a dot
terminal file and it's to export your
preferences for terminal and so you know
your background colors and all that but
one of the things you can have in there
is a start up command and when the
terminal opens it'll just run this
command every
time and so you can create this terminal
file export it and then when it's open
it will run whatever code you had in
that block that that opened on startup
block so that was great and we use that
on mac down and a few other ones but
also in things like sublime text which
are definitely not built on browser
technology it's just that the preview
window for markdown and even though it
has no like necessarily unsafe
integrations the default behavior for
opening this app file is to execute it
and because it's not a binary it happily
executes it and because it's actually in
a file colon path gatekeeper which
usually block to you from executing
things you've downloaded from the
internet it doesn't believe that this is
remote because it lives on slash net
slash whatever directory so that's
that's not very very good the so the
other thing we can take advantage of is
a javascript bridge a lot of the
applications like JetBrains and things
like that they have a similar approach
they don't have node built in but they
have integrations where they have some
Java on the client application side that
they can invoke from the web application
itself so you know the and then those
have like API calls to do different
things so we can abuse the same like
open an external browser because it's
typically done in an unsafe way but we
can invoke it directly with the string
we control and we can bypass the
validation that they had in their
renderer for your HTML links which is
great there's a few ways to find these I
mean so this was great for jetbrains
because there are open source versions
of some of their products and a lot of
the you know interactions are all are
all
easy to find most electron apps packaged
in a SAR file which is just as basically
this is it format that they support but
there's an easy way to extract those and
then go through the source and then if
not like if you have JavaScript
execution you know it's it's pretty
trivial to do document not write to dump
out you know like list all the objects
that that aren't part of a normal window
and from those give me all of the
functions that I can invoke the he one
of the integrations that was most
shocking to me was text me text mate
just had a system command and the system
command just ran whatever you put into
it it was kind of interesting on this
one because this is also available
through their HTML preview window so if
you are editing an HTML file I want to
see what it looks like or if you happen
to open a an HTML file that is malicious
and in clicked preview
it could just call system calls there's
another issue with text night where it
would where you could automatically
invoke preview from a web URL so you
could force that to happen you don't
actually have to preview a file so
that's calculator there and another one
that was kind of interesting and it was
the third bypass for visual studio code
and I wasn't necessarily trying to pick
on them they were just the first one
than the one I used myself the most so I
thought it's kind of interesting so
there's the external protocol handlers
or Skiba handlers that applications that
I talked about earlier with the CVE well
internally they're also used and they're
not exposed to the greater OS but
internally you know if I click on a link
and it calls this thing how does the
application interact or or you know
execute and these are everywhere
I mean eclipse has a lot of built-in
ones that that open up different panels
or hide or show different things all
based on these like URL schemas so
Visual Studio code in your rendered web
thing after they fixed all of their CSP
and all the other problems that they had
they still allowed you to create these
visual studio code
this is basically just invoking the
debugger and setting its type to note
and then passing an art - II just says
evaluate anything else I passed the
command line and then we have our normal
or payload from before to execute code
in a in the node context so that was
another unfortunate UV bypass for them
so if what if they're doing everything
correctly there what if there are no
external files or what if there's no
like external interface like node or
something else to interact with it's
really locked down like it should be
there's no bridge that you can exploit
what what else can we do you know most
of these render themselves they have
like some base HTML and then they render
into that and they load that from disk
right so they're loading this preview
HTML base from disk and so it's file
colon classes so the origin of this
window is a file origin that means that
we can read any other file from disk
that is of that same origin so what
happens if we read you know like at C
password or at the hosts or what if we
read your SSH keys from your local
directory like and then we can send
those because we're a file origin most
browsers are that it's kind of
privileged so file can go out but you
can't go down to file so file can I call
out to evil site and you control the
course headers for evil site so you can
allow that request to come out and this
happened in Eclipse which was kind of
interesting and there was a little bit
of talk around this bug and I don't
believe that they understood that it's
an issue so this is still available in
eclipse if you happen to have someone
preview a file for you that came out
kind of horrible but the other
interesting thing in eclipse which
doesn't have to do with bark down is
Java Docs so Java Doc's are just how you
comment they're just comments that
describe
classes and things like that but they're
actually used to you know give you type
information and things like that in your
IDE or to automatically like as you type
a method name to give you type
completion and stuff like that that
supports HTML and it's crazy because it
actually supports a limited only
supports a pretty limited subset of HTML
when you preview it and so I created an
image tag and it would preview the image
tag but it wouldn't preview the iframe
right so looking through there's a super
small subset of HTML tags that it
supports you know pretty basic
formatting
I don't know that big images and stuff
are very useful either so maybe they
should limit that some more but what is
interesting is if you mouse over the
method name in the code editor it tries
to pop up another window that shows you
the the your Java Doc's right so it's
showing you the method signatures and
all that trying to show you that in line
and that's not the same renderer that's
down here and that ends up for some
reason just popping up a brand new
window that's that's an embedded browser
and it has a really like a wider range
of HTML that it supports including being
able to read local files and send them
along so a few other things that that I
look for when I'm looking for Apps
JetBrains had a few more bypasses as
well
they had a built in API like a built-in
local server running on a random port
and it had some a key that you had to
use to interface with it but because I
could read local files I could get the
key and then once I had the key from the
local file I could make calls to like
open a project and then that project
could have an auto start script in it
and then it could execute so there there
are plenty of other by pests and ways
around these things so look for open
ports look for open you know any any
other things that any Damons they run
things like that looking at the render
code was really fun because the markdown
editor you know there are ways to bypass
like it's it's floor mat and
handling like if I created a link but it
has a double quote in it how good is
your markdown renderer is it going to
break out of the HTML tags or not a
deprecated but still available
everywhere tag is the X and P tag and it
will just show HTML of everything under
it it's like the pre tag is supposed to
be for formatting but it actually just
dumps all of the rest of HTML so you can
see if there's anything any new
JavaScript injected below you which
happens a lot or you can see like how
exactly it's rendering if you're messing
up HTML tags by breaking markdown
sparser and so oh yeah so markdown files
also I needed to know the path that the
application was opened in and I and that
wasn't always resolvable but if I did a
relative link to a file you could read
the URL from the relative link that was
that was handy and electron also has a
flag that you can pass which is Daffy -
inspect and then you can use Chrome's
remote debugger to completely you know
analyze everything you're doing there
just like you would a normal web page
and most apps don't block that I think
it happens before an application starts
so if you were trying to find issues in
a electron app that you don't have the
source to that can be a really super
handy feature I didn't I wanted to show
basically what not to do by example I
didn't create a checklist or a list of
like this is the right way to do it a
couple of people have though and I
definitely wanted to call them out Luka
sorry I'm not gonna try he had he did a
really good talk at blackhat this year
and he has a new great checklist for
electron that covers a really wide range
he actually found a few CVS and electron
as well and so if you can find his stuff
it's it's really super interesting and
electron has their own security readme
there are some definite issues with that
readme and some of their advice but
overall it's definitely something you
should try to follow
I have you know a lot more details about
each of these I'll be posting them now
as soon as the silver and if you have
any other questions or comments I'll be
happy to take those but if if you can't
find me afterwards or now you can find
me on Twitter and I went short
[Applause]